it's great to welcome to the program
today Ross Douthat who's a columnist at
the New York Times and also author of
the recent book the decadent society how
we became the victims of our own success
great to have you on Ross thank you yeah
thanks for having me it's a pleasure so
a lot of what you write about applies to
the situation in which we find ourselves
today but in order to kind of get into
that conversation when you talk about a
decadent society what do you mean by
that because it may it may not be
obvious to some in our audience right so
I'm trying to use the word decadence not
to just mean you know chocolate-covered
strawberries and you know bondage dens
and orgies and so on but I'm trying to
use it as a kind of technical label for
a stage that really successful
civilizations tend to reach when they
become very rich and powerful and all of
their sort of systems governmental
economic are well established
hard to change we're on it
any comment essentially victims of their
own success they're so powerful and rich
that they stop doing the kind of things
that you need to do to innovate both in
politics and science and culture they
stop having as many babies because you
know people have other things to do with
their time and so they enter into
periods and sort of torpor stagnation
and repetition which the book argues
we've been in at least up until you know
the current crisis that we entered into
while I was on my book course how does
this relate to some of the systems that
up until three months ago many of us
maybe assumed were pretty strong and
whose fragility has actually been
exposed by the corona virus does that in
any way play into this stagnation sort
of that that you apply to economies that
in countries that are in this decadent
phase where we very quickly realized hey
that great-looking stock market was
actually not quite so strong the supply
chain for many consumer products and
even some food items was not nearly as
strong as we believed employment was not
as strong as we believed how does that
play into this idea it plays in in I
mean in a lot of different ways but I'll
give you a couple examples
is you know the point that you made
about supply chains one of the things
that the Western world has been doing
basically over the last 40 years is
overall growth has been slowing down
growth hasn't been nearly as impressive
as it was you know in the heyday of the
Industrial Revolution or the post-war
boom and so we've been trying to
essentially do two things one spend way
more money way more public money
basically and take on way more debt in
order to sort of create the sense that
we're still growing quickly and to we're
trying to wring out sort of maximal
efficiencies everywhere we can find them
in order to again sort of Goose growth
and with supply chains and you know
things like our basic supplies of
medical equipment and masks and so on
you can see the danger in in the second
trend where you're you know you're so
focused on efficiency because you know
that you know you won't get strong
growth without maximal efficiency that
you aren't actually prepared to be
flexible when a real crisis comes along
and turns out that efficiency isn't the
only good it's also good to have
stockpiles of medical equipment so
that's one one sort of pattern and
another pattern is just the way sort of
large bureaucracies by their nature are
built to pursue safety rather than
innovation and that's not a bad thing
per se obviously you want the FDA and
the CDC to be focused on making sure
that medicine is safe and vaccines are
safe and so on but it makes them
inflexible not particularly adaptable
and you end up in this case with the
sort of temporary catastrophe like the
kind we had with testing in this country
over over the critical two months when
we missed the opportunity to contain the
virus where the bureaucracies default
mode is sort of the status quo is fine
and we just need to make sure
everything's safe and when you actually
have a new challenge
you can't adapt to it particularly
quickly now when we think about so the
first element you mentioned with the
medical supplies it doesn't seem to me
as though the countries that are not yet
at a level of what what you described as
decadence uniformly did better on that
issue I mean there was certainly a mix
there were countries that were more
proactive South Korea China
not not China Taiwan I believe that
within Europe Greece certainly was one
that moved earlier and sort of more
aggressively but what other factors
should we be looking at because it's not
it can't simply be that it was decadence
that sort of prevented us from being
properly ready for that no it's also
just immediate experience right I mean
you you have a clear division between
how quickly and seriously East Asian
societies and East Asian politics took
this challenge and have seriously the US
and Western Europe took it mostly
because it's not just that the East
Asian countries were in closer proximity
to China they also have sort of direct
experience of SARS you know in the
immediate past so they had sort of some
knowledge and a sense of how bad things
could get and sort of you know a sense
of the need to act quickly in a crisis
whereas in the US and Western Europe
there was a sense that well you know
something can happen in China and it
must be you know well it's just a
Chinese problem it's the kind of thing
that you know could only happen in you
know what I think a lot of people in the
West still think of China as a
developing country a country that sort
of fundamentally different from the
developed world which it is in certain
ways but obviously not in others so
there's just I think yeah a level of
sort of recent experience and realism
about the real state of the world that
was stronger in East Asia than in the US
and Western Europe and I also think you
could say in at a larger level that
there are ways in which generally the
economies of East Asia do look a little
less decadent generally than well
certainly than Western Europe but also
in the u.s. in terms of sort of their
general willingness to sort of embrace
innovation they're sort of a state
capacity this term of art that people
use to refer to you know how good a
government is and getting things done
state capacity seems like it's been in
decline in the US over the last few
decades and maybe less so in East Asia
so there's a lot of different dynamics
going on so as we see in the in the
United States even though at the country
level we could say we are certainly one
of
richest countries in the world we have
achieved a degree of what you describe
as decadence the reality about
inequality means that for a large number
of people only maybe a sliver of some of
these benefits are actually reaching
them when you look at you know wage
growth over the last 40 years and how it
disproportionately has been for a small
upper echelon of the economy so to speak
or workers as the case may be what is
the relationship between a country that
top level has achieved this status that
you identify to the degree to which it's
uniformly or not uniformly distributed
amongst the people I think it depends I
think I think there are a couple
different ways that you can get
inequality and one is more decadent and
one is less decadent right so if you
look at a period like late nineteenth
century America you have soaring
inequality you have the year of the
robber barons the great fortunes of the
Rockefellers and Carnegie's were being
made and that created all kinds of
social problems that eventually sort of
led to the labor movements of populist
and progressive you're and the New Deal
but it wasn't an inequality that really
reflected decadence it was an inequality
that reflected this age of innovation
where you had sudden innovations a few
people were capturing the returns and it
took a while for those returns to spread
throughout the population our own era
the last 30 years or so it looks like
that a little bit with Silicon Valley
where you have you know Internet
innovation does occur Berg's and and so
on get rich and it doesn't spread out to
the rest of society but a lot of what
we've seen outside the internet economy
is a steady stagnation slowing rates of
growth where rich people aren't getting
rich by embracing innovative new
technologies they're getting rich just
through the power of investments and
compound interest and so on and this is
Thomas Piketty this is sort of the
argument it says this is not this is the
more libertarian in a way version of the
argument that he made in his book
capital in the 21st century where he
basically said you know as societies
sort of as growth slows down and
societies get older and people have see
where kid
great fortunes become more and more
consolidated and rich people live off
ramps and that kind of inequality is
more decadent and more stagnant and less
likely to ultimately benefit society as
a whole than the inequality you get when
you know people are building the
Transcontinental Railroad and a lot of
opportunists are getting rich off that
innovation one of the things you talk
about in the book is the degree to which
a lot of the same political arguments
just continue to be had over and over
again with no real progress once a
country reaches this level of decadence
and I think we can intuitively see that
if you follow politics a lot of issues
that are merely political footballs you
know debt and deficit just kind of
tossing it back and forth what should
the role of the United States military
be around the world do low taxes on the
rich trickle down or do we need to man
sites that you know a lot of these that
it's the same arguments over and over
and over again can you talk about why
the repetitive nature of these arguments
is reinforced by the decadence you write
about I mean I think decadence creates a
world in which I mean among other things
there because there isn't tremendous
change going on there aren't sort of it
it becomes hard to win an argument to
sort of decisively win one way or
another systems are really hard to
reform and change so you know you'll get
Barack Obama will be elected president
and everyone will say oh this is you
know the new New Deal is the new
Franklin Roosevelt you're gonna have a
new age of liberal governance and he
passes Obamacare which is sort of a
jerry-rigged apparatus tacked on to an
existing welfare state passing it is
incredibly difficult and politically
costly and you get a huge backlash and
effectively his presidency as a
legislative force is over two years in
and then immediately the Tea Party
sweeps in and everyone says ah well it's
a new libertarian era and you know Paul
Ryan is the new you know he's the new
great reformer and he's gonna you know
undo the Great Society or something but
that doesn't actually go anywhere
because people don't particularly want
to undo the Great Society and so you
have you know the libertarian moment
quickly turns into stalemate too so it's
a combination of societies get older
they're more resistant to change
big programs long-standing systems are
more impervious to change and so people
argue at the margins they argue about a
39 percent top tax rate versus a 33% top
tax rate even while their rhetoric makes
it sound like you know it's the great
clash between capitalism and socialism
and since so that's been the pattern
certainly I think of the last of the
last 25 years or so the question is
whether it still holds or whether
populism on the right and Bernie Sanders
style socialism on the left are actually
going to sort of shift the underlying
dynamics but I don't think they've
actually shifted policy debates yet even
if they've shifted argument somewhat so
you talk about candidates as a possible
way to shift this what about your
writing that there could be a crisis
moment that actually shakes things up is
the global pandemic we're dealing with
now but potentially on the level of what
you're talking about or is it not even
big enough I mean it might not be big
enough well which is one of the things
one of the points I make in the book is
that decadence has all kinds of problems
but sometimes the kind of crisis you
need to really shift a society out of
decadence is so big that it's better to
stick with that Center embrace the
catastrophe but look what the
coronavirus offers is an opportunity you
know it's it's a whole you know it's a
horrible human tragedy that in its
aftermath there will be an opportunity
to look at all the ways our systems have
failed to look at all the ways our
politics has become stalemated and
didn't handle the crisis correctly and
say you know maybe we can do something
new and that could lead to you know you
could have an era when people say okay
well we really are going to you know
change how regulations work in the
healthcare sector to try and get more
medical innovation you've dipped in a
world where people say look we spent all
this money in a crisis why can't we
spend more money on public goods when
there isn't a pandemic around it so you
get a shift to the left in public policy
you can imagine a lot of shifts coming
out of this but I do think it's possible
that you know we will have this this
year of turmoil and then we will get
scene and there'll be sort of this sense
of relief that things are back to normal
and people will have sort of gone deeper
into decadence in certain ways like you
know small businesses new
entrepreneurship will have been sort of
smushed down big companies will
benefited the most from the bailout
packages and from the feds policies
until you'll get more consolidation more
big companies that aren't particularly
innovative and so on you know more
people living their lives online and
instead of instead of getting married
and starting families you can imagine a
lot of ways in which this deepens
decadence potentially even as it offers
a chance to pull out of it a couple
weeks ago I interviewed Brian Greene and
one of the things we talked about
because it kind of mixes in well with a
few different things he deals with was
this idea that that I have which
increasingly I think is naive that if
there was some really life-altering
moment like for example intelligent
alien life arrives right something
really transcendent that it would
finally get humans to do away with these
differences that that as you talk about
often or the difference between a thirty
six and a thirty nine point six percent
top tax rate or whatever we would
finally get past all this stuff but I
have to say that the the fiasco that has
been the reaction to coronavirus where
you have people who you know all sorts
of conspiracies and you all we don't
even have to go into it you know it that
has made me think that even something
like intelligent alien life maybe for a
month would would get us to rethink some
of our differences and then it would all
just kind of go back to normal to the
way things have been I don't know well I
mean the amusing thing is that we have
literally had sort of footage of not
probably not actual aliens but at the
very least UFOs dropped in the middle of
the coronavirus crisis right you've had
the the Navy releasing footage of
unidentified flying objects and you know
except for a few people who I follow on
Twitter almost nobody has cared to be
clear that those are not being presented
as evidence of aliens right but but
regardless you would think that that
entire community would have paid more
attention there
right they're being presented but they
are they're very mysterious objects that
are then go beyond I think the sort of
normal range of sort of grainy footage
of UFOs they are probably not aliens but
they certainly are really interesting
and in a different moment you would
imagine that sort of capturing the
imagination of the Internet but really
the Internet is more interested in you
know figuring out ways to blame
everything about the coronavirus on on
people that they dislike we've been
speaking with Ross Douthat
a columnist at the New York Times and
also author recently of the decadent
Society how we became the victims of our
own success Russ I so appreciate your
time thanks so much for having me it was
a pleasure